as the saying goes behind every great
man is a great woman in the case of NCIS
is Special Agent leroy jethro gibbs
played by Mark Harmon that woman is his
first wife Shannon portrayed by Darby
Stanchfield we only see Shannon Gibbs in
flashbacks on NCIS as she and their
daughter Kelly were killed in a car
accident arranged by a drug dealer that
took place over a decade before the show
is set so even though NCIS seems to be
plain whenever you turn on the TV
Stansfield Shannon isn't as familiar as
some of the other characters however
there's a good chance you'll know
Stanchfield from somewhere else here's
why Shannon Gibbs from NCIS looks so
familiar NCIS has consistently ranked as
the most watched drama in the u.s. but
it's far from the only hit show
Stanchfield has been involved with one
of her very first TV jobs was on an
episode of angel the spinoff a beloved
supernatural drama series Buffy the
Vampire Slayer Stanchfield also had a
small role on everyone's favorite box
set of the double odds 24 playing
Mandy's ill-fated neighbor Shari
elsewhere in the early to mid 2000s air
of her career Stansfield popped up on
that 80's show monk it's all relative
strong medicine without a trace and
nip/tuck just before landing her NCIS
gig the actress secured a job on Jericho
CBS's post-apocalyptic action drama that
ran for just two seasons before it was
canceled Stansfield portrayed April
Green a doctor at a Medical Center in
the fictional town of Jericho Kansas her
stent lasted just over a dozen episodes
with her characters arc ending in death
from their Stansfield took over the
character of Amelia jaw on General
Hospital for ten episodes in 2007 and
then booked a recurring role on the
iconic drama series Mad Men
she played Helen Bishop the divorcee who
scandalized 60 suburbia for five
episodes on the first two seasons of the
series of course if you dubbed I'm set
I'm joking it took a while for
Stanchfield to land another character
who came back for more than one episode
but she worked consistently on many
well-known shows she has had one-off
appearances on bones private practice
The Mentalist Ghost Whisperer and even
How I Met Your Mother on when she played
the snobby former tenant of Marshall &
Ted's apartment after booking NCIS
Stanchfield doubled down on the crime
angle with two separate roles on CSI New
York and CSI Miami you may also know her
as Richard castle's first ex-wife from
the comedic crime series Castle having
popped up for one or two episodes of
numerous hit shows Stanchfield landed
another major recurring role in 2012 on
the Shonda Rhimes created political
thriller series scandal the actress
played Abby Whelan the outspoken former
press secretary and chief of staff at
the White House and the mostly loyal
best friend and colleague to Kerry
Washington's Olivia Pope Stansfield also
got the chance to influence Olivia
Pope's world off-screen she created and
directed a promotional web series called
scandal gladiator wanted which was
released a week before the show's season
6 premiere
she must have impressed the showrunners
because she later got the chance to
direct an episode of the final season
the 15th episode entitled the noise if
you're more into supernatural demons
than lawyers you may know Stansfield
from her most recent role she played
Nina Locke on Netflix his adaptation of
the graphic novel series lock and key
which hit the streaming platform on
February 7 2020 Stanchfield plays the
mother of three children who returned to
their father's childhood home after he
is killed the fun and fright starts when
they find mysterious keys and unlock
supernatural portals and attract a
demonic force
Nina Locke is also an alcoholic which
gives Stanfield and emotional new
challenge to tackle in the role although
Netflix hasn't confirmed anything yet
the ending of lock-and-key hinted that
there could be a second season meaning
Stansfield could be back for more spooks
and scares either way it looks like
Stansfield's long-running career isn't
slowing down anytime soon
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]